there is only one person who was in the
house the night JonBenet Ramsey was
murdered that we have never heard from
her brother Burke dr. Phil scored the
exclusive interview with a noun
grown-up Burke Ramsey the first thing I
remember is my mom first thing in my
room really frantic saying like oh my
gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh
running around my room looking for a job
in a brook Ramsey was only nine years
old when his sister Jon Benet was
murdered nearly 20 years ago and in all
the years since he's never spoken about
in public until now the next thing I
remember is a police officer coming to
my room and shining a flashlight how in
the world did you convince Burke Jama
days brother to do this interview well
you know it's the 20-year anniversary
his thinking was if that's gonna happen
I want to control the narrative we go to
the supermarket sometimes and there be a
tabloid dominates pictured plastered on
the front just made me a very private
person long considered suspects but
ultimately cleared in the murder were
Burke's dad John and his noun deceased
mother Pat's I love that job even Burke
was once a suspect I've heard rumors but
we were hiding Burke because he was this
crazy kid there are times when he's
talking about very heavy dark content
mm-hmm but yet he's smiling did you go
to JonBenet's funeral yeah I remember
the viewing I remember the casket small
and her eyes were closed
did he ever understand that people on
the outside were looking at him and
saying you are a suspect as he got older
he became aware that he was a suspect I
asked him straight up did you murder Jon
Benet your sisters
oh you knew dr. Phil was not going to
mince words